الامريكية. بوتين يخرج بعضا من
اوراقه الرابحة. فهل هناك اوراق
اليهود من حركة ناتور كارتا
اليهودية المناهضة للصهيونية في
فعاليات احياء ذكرى النكبة
الفلسطينية دينة نيويورك
النواب الليبي بالاغلبية على
اقالة رئيس الحكومة الليبية
اخرى للجزيرة الديموقراطية التي
تتمتع بحكم ذاتي. صوت مجلس
التابع لحلف الذي يتخذ من
العاصمة الاستونية تلين مقرا له.
تؤدي الى اعتقال الروسي ميخائيل
ماديف الذي يشتبه بتورطه في
والتي اعلنت عن مكافأة تصل الى
عشرة ملايين دولار مقابل معلومات
بينما يرى الروس ان اي مشاركة
نكرانية في مجال الامن السيبراني
الالكترونية او ما يطلق عليها
بالسيبراني. حيث اعلنت وزارة
تعلن انها ستنشر قاذفات صواريخ
هايمرز الامريكية الصنع شمالي
الضيقة بالوساطة? ام ان لافريقيا
رأيا اخر? ومن جانب اخر بولندا
اوكرانيا منذ بدء حرب روس على
اوكرانيا. وسيتجه لي ايضا الى
المكلف من البرلمان فتحي باشاجا
واحالته للتحقيق. شارك حاخامات
روسيا وعدد من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي. فهل ينجح اصحاب العيون
الصحافة الفرنسية. ويعتبر لي
اعلى دبلوماسي صيني يزور
ميدفيديف عن سؤال ماذا ستفعل
روسيا بعد انسحابها من معاهدة
ديمتري ميدفيديف ان روسيا ستعزز
تاج الاسلحة والمعدات العسكرية
حيث تشارك مصر والقادة الافارقة
لبحث افاق اوكرانية ضمن مبادرة
السلام. ليصرح رئيس جمهورية جنوب
افريقيا سيرير رامافوزا بان
هنا الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان
قديروف يتوعى القادة الاوكرانيين
المتحدة تسريع وتيرة بيع اسلحة
دفاعية وتقديم مساعدات عسكرية
قائلا الله اكبر سنقتحم كييف على
متن هذه الدبابة. لتتجه كييف نحو
الخارجية الاوكرانية انضمام كييب
رسميا الى عمل المركز السيبراني
منطقة تشيرنييف بالقرب من الحدود
مع بيلاروسيا فهل هو تحرش
اي محاولة لابتزاز موسكو. فهل
فهمتم ايها الغربيون تقولها
لسحق اي شكل من اشكال استقلال
تايوان بحزم بما تستعد الولايات
موسكو. الاحداث والتطورات. اكد
الجيش الصيني ان الصين مستعدة
اوكراني بانتظار رد مسك. ومن
رائحة البارود الى حمائم السلام.
الابتزاز الالكتروني في امريكا.
لنستمر قليلا في الحرب
ومن قوة روسيا الى قوة حليفته
الشيشانية. ومن على متن دبابته
خصم اقل قوة من روسيا. حيث اجرى
الجيش الاوكراني تدريبات في
الحمراء. فهل من رد روسي? لننتقل
نحو ولايات المتحدة الامريكية
الاسلحة التقليدية. ماذا بقي من
اسلحة روسية لم تظهر بعد يا هذا؟
والخاصة وكذلك وسائل التدمير الى
الحد الاقصى وذلك حين اجاب
شرقي البلاد في منطقة حدودية مع
روسيا والناتو يتجاوز خطوط روسيا
للنزاع في اوكرانيا لهوي قد بدأ
زيارته الى كييف بحسب وكالة
كان الممثل الصيني الخاص للشؤون
الاوراسية المكلف بمناقشة تسوية
انضمت مع سفينتين حربيتين اخريين
مزودتين بصواريخ بعيدة المدى
واسلحة توصف بانها الاكثر قوة
للجبهة. ودعم سياسي من الاتحاد
وعالية الدقة. مهلا مهلا مهلا.
فالدب الروسي لا يمل من اظهار
الروسي خلف جبهة القتال. فهل
يسكت الروس عن ذلك? هنا قرقرة
الاوروبي. فهل يكفي ما حمله
زلينسكي برأيكم? يبدو بانه لا
يرجى اعادة تعبئة رصيدكم. فما هي
البدائل امام كييف? وها هي تاتي
الامريكي يعلنها. معذرة لقد اوشك
رصيد دعمكم الامريكي على النفاذ
وهي اول فرقاطة شبحية لدعم
قواتها ضد الهجمات الاوكرانية اذ
من الرئيس الاوكراني فولوديمر
زينينسكي الذي قال انه يعود الى
بلاده بعد جولته الاوروبية التي
حصل خلالها على حزم دفاع جديدة
الروسي في البحر الاسود. نعم.
انها الفرقاطة الملقبة بعطارد
يكفي. حيث ادخل بوتين ورقة من
اوراقه الرابحة الى الاسطول
المعدة الاوكرانية تعلن نفاذ
ذخيرة الجيش الاوكراني والدعم
روسيا واوكرانيا وافقتا على
وساطة الدول الافريقية. بينما
قوته المرعبة. حيث قال نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن في الاتحاد الروسي
اوكرانيا بدأت باستخدام صواريخ
لضرب اهداف روسية وفق ما نقلت سي
ان ان الامريكية وذلك لضرب
مستودعات الامداد في العمق
معارك طاحنة منذ عدة اشهر. افاد
مسؤولون امريكيون وغربيون ان
اوكرانيا تحقيق مكاسب امام الروس
قرب مدينة باخموت. حيث تدور
المسلحة الاوكرانية ان ثمانية
عشر صاروخا اطلقت نحو كييف وحدها
الاعنف منذ فترة بحسب الدفاع
الروسية. وتزامنا مع اعلان
كاملة من عدة صواريخ فوق صوتي.
واذا تأكد هذا فسيكون دليلا على
بانه قد تم اسقاطها جميعا. لكن
ذلك الهجوم الصاروخي الروسي هو
الروسي لم يتأخر. لتعلن الدفاع
الروسي يغمص كنجال الروسي انقض
كييف. هنا اعلنت الحكومة
الاوكرانية عن حالة التأهب
على اقوى منظومة امريكية نعم
الخنجر الروسي يذبح باتريوت في
والمناطق المحيطة بها وذلك بعد
ان اكد القائد العام للقوات
ستة من صواريخ الاسرع من الصوت
في ليلة والتي تقول موسكو بانها
بحسب رويترز. فكيف سترد موسكو
اذا؟ وبسرعة صاروخ كنجال الرد
فعالية الدفاعات الجوية الغربية
التي نشرت في الاونة الاخيرة
الارض الاوكرانية. هنا تعلن
القوات الاوكرانية انها اسقطت
للغارات الجوية في جميع مناطق
اوكرانيا تقريبا بما في ذلك كييف
لا تقر وهي المرة الاولى التي
تعلن فيها اوكرانيا اسقاط دفعة
تايوان رغم انف الولايات
المتحدة. حرب الاوراق الرابحة.
امريكية ضخمة لمن ياتي بشخص روسي
حيا او ميتا وبكين تستعد لسحق
الحرب تشتد وكل يخرج اوراقه
المخبأة ليحقق شيئا على خارطة
بلاده محملا بما سيشعل غضب الدب
الروسي. ومجددا اوكرانيا تتحرش
بقوة. بينما تشارك مصر في خطة
سلام افريقية حرب اوكرانيا
الى اسطول البحر الاسود. فهل
تحسم هذه الورقة حرب اوكرانيا
وروسيا. فماذا عن المبادرة
الصينية؟ موسكو تضع خطة مرعبة
القوات الاوكرانية تعلن اسقاط
سلاح روسي لا يقهر والكرملين يرد
عسكريا ببلاروسيا. فكيف سترد
مسك. بوتين يدخل ورقته الرابحة
لما بعد انسحابها من اتفاقية
ستارت النووية. وزينيسكي يعود
امريكية تتحضر لمواجهة روسيا على
الحدود مع بولندا. ولاول مرة.
سنقتحم كييف وعلى زلنسكي ان يجهز
حقائبه للمغادرة. قاذفات صواريخ
تكمل بنفسها مخازننا نفدت.
وقديروف يشعل الحرب من جديد.
واشنطن تعلنها. انهينا دورنا في
الحرب الاوكرانية وعلى كييف ان
بحوزة اوكرانيا وتخبئها للنهاية?